the year is 2019 it's about to be 2020
and three years ago we released the
project called rush it was a battlefield
web series we're not calling it
Battlefield anymore to do a whole bunch
of legal Fiasco's that happened along
the way but the point is an idea was
based around the game Gold Rush and Gold
Rush was started in Battlefield Bad
Company where you're going to destroy
caches of gold the ideas that have
characters where there's two squads and
each person that squad represents the
basic classes of battlefield assault
recon support and engineer so it wrote a
story around this where it's basically
taking that concept and turning it into
an actual movie and I'm really happy
with how he managed to craft a story
around that I think it's route really
cool another thing is we got to work
with real blank firing machine guns real
tanks helicopters the great actors all
this amazing stuff we are releasing the
project on our YouTube channel this is a
very special release this is a
remastered edition and I'm not talking
like a George Lucas reimagining
remastering kind of process I'm talking
about taking a project that when it was
originally released was about 60 percent
completed I'm talking like literally
sound design there was multiple scenes
upon its original release that had
nothing in it except like a music track
playing really awkward a lot of the
visual effects were handed off to like a
really really really cheap overseas post
house safe to say the original release
was pretty flawed and we've done our
best to remaster it I've gone through
and took a ton of new visual effects
egos applied a new color grade to the
whole thing and I've even gone through
and fix a ton of sound design a lot of
work has gone into it so far and we're
really really excited to show it to you
guys I'm gonna show you a little bit
today about what some of those updates
are so for this we basically take in ten
episodes and compress them into five so
that each one is nice and meaty let's
start with the biggest biggest biggest
one because I think this is a great way
to start
imagine sitting in a theater of about
200 other crew members cast members
seeing the premiere and then having to
watch this in front of them
we even had we had actual footage for
that they just didn't use it by the way
for some of the explosion flies sideways
the left and then he's just like what is
going on seeing that it was the most
embarrassing thing I've ever felt that
is why I started with this sequence Sam
is very motivated when gets angry do you
want it just straight-up see what
happened now yeah I put in a lot of work
[Applause]
beginning still a little janky can't fix
it but whoa
it gets way better so I did that too
like your father day or two I'm even
still critiquing it now because there's
issues but it's way way better it's not
cringe-worthy you're still out some
visual effects are happening but you're
not like is this on iMovie so ready for
another spice spice Meister before
there's they did hone in on the detail
of making the window orange to signify
that there was heat okay so in this
scene the building is supposed to
collapse if you have a shot in a story
that's supposed to communicate that
something falls apart and it doesn't so
this shot I was just like all right you
know what I'm not the best 3d artist but
I sure can some pixels Wow
I literally took an image down from the
ground and I projection map that onto a
big-ass structure and then I took that
big-ass structure I fragmented it I went
all in on this one because it's kind of
what you needed to do
oh so extra chunks still gets pretty
smoky at the end so at least it
communicates what the frickin heck was
supposed to happen in the scene and not
trying to pretend that I'm the magic
visual effects artist I'm just trying to
finish the dang shots that we set out to
do the artist who did the smoke
simulations didn't do that bad of a job
it's just they didn't have anything else
to work with like the rest of the piece
here do smoke simulations is like what
about the building collapsing like one
of the very first things that we had to
cut when we were confronted with the
reality of not finishing this project
were a lot of them like bullet hits on
people thankfully we we did have some
blank firing guns on set and a couple
occasional squibs so we felt like those
kind of practical elements would kind of
cover our asses I just add like the
smallest amount of blood for him
originally he's like and then I use
freakin John with him and I put a splat
on the wall and made him die I am you
know Wow same with this look at this
idiot he's like boom his chest vapes I
can fix the squib so I can add bullet
hits but I can't change bad acting
he runs through a door and go
here's another great example so there's
a missile helicopter sequence in this
what's wrong with this visual effects
shot the helicopter and the missile are
moving through 3d space the problem is
is that it looks like the visual effects
artist here basically didn't account for
like the wind the turning of the
helicopter in the world the smoke is
stuck to the helicopter it like the
whole background and the camera movement
and all that stuff completely ignored so
I'm like you know what I'm just going to
completely reconstruct this shot I'm
going to chop out the helicopter element
but I'm gonna put in a brand new
background so that way I can control how
the helicopter moves through the
environment so if the ground is fake the
sky is fake
the Misses fake but the helicopter is
real and the 3d camera movement is real
it just looks the motion looks natural
everything like a spatially cohesive and
here's a great here's here's a great
shot and so we redid that one actually
Clint did this one rather than trying
rerender a new missile flying around on
this guy we're like let's just do the
cameras perspective of missile like the
thermal sensor this is the replacement
boom there we go now we are
communicating that our missile is locked
back on when it originally came out
Nikko yeah we're like man the color
great suck so bad and I was sitting
there going what wasn't that bad was it
but after seeing what Nico's don't do it
I'm like oh thanks
you've been lightened me finally like
you're right also I had this handy-dandy
black magic panel which made it way
faster that was really nice I felt
really cool I guess driving a spaceship
mmm so yeah that's basically a good
overview of the effects there's a lot
more can I keep working on it yes but I
think it serves a purpose right now if
this piece I brought it from like a
solid like 2 out of 10 to like a 7 out
of 10
yeah I need three effects shots in 10
days yeah that's why it's not perfect
but it's definitely improvement so we
have toiled away taking one of the
biggest projects we've ever made and
made it even better it's on youtube.com
slash corridor our corridor channel link
in the description below it is so nice
to be able to finally release it for
everyone around the world to watch
you've already seen it you're gonna
enjoy it even more this time because
it's way better if you haven't seen it
yet well this is the perfect time to
watch five episodes go enjoy it
we like them I've ever felt anything
like it
they're alive